the most comfortable men's boxers and
t-shirts you'll ever find are at leisure
of NYC their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers
feel as light as air and their silky
smooth supima cotton crewneck t-shirts
are amazing I love them you'll get 15
off with code Pacman at davidpackman.com
NYC well my friends inflation has come
in and it has come in low and if we want
to participate
in this ridiculous game wherein we say
well if inflation going up was Joe
Biden's fault then inflation coming down
must be credited to Joe Biden now you
and I and many of the people that are in
our audience kind of prefer to operate
more in the real world where we don't
play these political games with gas
prices and with inflation so let's not
play them let's just look at the data
and understand that inflation is a
global phenomenon and we're going to
look at Global numbers and we're going
to punch the microphone as I often do
when I get excited uh and we'll
hopefully have an understanding of the
fact that this is something that
shouldn't really surprise us because
it's been the most likely trajectory for
a while although in general we are not
particularly good as humans at making
economic predictions it did seem as
though inflation peaked some months ago
and it would be lower by the end of the
year and indeed it is so let's start
with the data CNBC reporting consumer
Prices rose less than expected in
November up 7.1 percent from a year ago
the Consumer Price Index Rose just 0.1
percent from the previous month
increased 7.1 percent from a year ago
compared with respective estimates of
0.3 and 7.3 percent core CPI the
Consumer Price Index Rose 0.2 percent on
the month and six percent on an annual
basis compared with respective estimates
of 0.3 percent and 6.1 percent stocks
soared uh the Dow is as of right now up
about 400 points inflation adjusted
average hourly earnings for workers Rose
0.5 percent for the month though they
were still down 1.9 percent from a year
ago now whenever we do these numbers
there's confusion David wait
are prices up or are they down what does
it mean it but if Prices rose how are
they down remember that there are two
components to this what happened last
month and how does adding the data from
last month change the last 12 months of
inflation so remember
we want a little bit of inflation we
have an economy and I know that this
gets into well do we really buy into
this traditional economic stuff and I
get that I get that but
the sort of standard view is you want a
little bit of inflation a little bit of
inflation is good why if you have a ton
of inflation Things become unaffordable
so people stop buying which hurts
businesses so they lay people off and
then those people have no money to buy
stuff and it's bad for the economy
that's too much inflation if you have
deflation it might sound good you might
say Sir ma'am it's cheaper stuff is good
deflation sounds good no it's not good
for the economy why
if you expect prices to continue
declining if you're looking at a car
right an electric vehicle for example
and you expect because we're in a
deflationary situation that if you wait
six months the prices will be lower you
wouldn't buy the car that's bad for the
businesses the employees at the electric
car businesses get laid off because
nobody's buying cars because you expect
prices to go down so the idea is a
little bit of inflation creates an
incentive to buy now rather than later
it's not so much that Things become
unaffordable and that is where economic
growth comes from now believe me I'll be
the first to tell you those sort of
completely rational actor economic
analyzes lack a very real component I am
with you but those are the oranges for
lack of a better term of why a little
bit of inflation is good getting us back
to the numbers
in there was a little bit of inflation
last month but compared to November of
21 it was lower so when we replace in
the one-year inflation number the
November 21 number with the November 22
number year over year inflation is lower
okay so that's that uh Dow surge is 400
points as investors cheer the light
inflation report you know I don't put a
lot of stock in these types of headlines
I I think it's important to remember
that
uh you know to some degree
this has been predicted for months so if
markets were completely efficient and
and rational
this this new data would have already
been priced in it doesn't really make
sense that the Dow pops because the data
was what it is but the expectation on
paper was of slightly higher inflation
and it came in lower okay if you're in
the market it's a good day and as many
of you know much of the return in the
markets happens on just 10 days out of
the year today may be one of those days
lastly remember that inflation is a
global phenomenon and when you look at
the inflation rates these this is data
from October in some countries and
November in some you see that among
wealthier and larger Nations Nations
that are part of this list we're looking
at the trading economics.com list you
see that the US is sort of like right in
the middle now with year-over-year
inflation at 7.1 percent down from you
know the high eights and you see that
for example in Italy and in the UK
inflation is significantly higher
uh
whereas in Brazil and France and
Singapore and Spain inflation is lower
than in the U.S has very little to do
with Joe Biden Global phenomenon U.S
sort of like right in the middle there
so this is overall I believe a good
thing inflation has been too high it has
been a strain on on American budgets and
hopefully this continues and we can get
down again we're just we're not good at
this but it would be nice to continue
seeing the year over year numbers ticked
down over the next six months where
maybe we can get to like the low fives
High fours by summertime and that would
be historically much more pleasant I
think is the word that I would use so
that's the latest on inflation I'm going
to play a video for you today it uh it
is a video of a right-wing meteorologist
going completely mental on Tucker
Carlson I thought I was on hallucinogens
I I thought maybe someone slipped acid
into my cappuccino or a flat white I've
been going more in the direction of the
flat white lately something about that
foam but that's really for a different
day I thought I was on something when I
saw this video because the video doesn't
make any sense a Fox News propagandist
Tucker Carlson who does entertainment
remember when if when when the rubber
hits the road
and Tucker gets sued uh lawyers go oh
this is not news this is entertainment
okay he did a segment an entertainment
segment I guess with a meteorologist
named Joe bastardi and that's that's
really his name I'm not I know people
will write in and say David that's
that's rude you're being rude by calling
him bastard no no his name's Joe
bastardi this video is so unbelievably
unhinged but it's a great representation
of how the right to a great degree
I was going to say analyzes but there's
really no analysis here deals with
topics they don't like the right gets
angry that for example people now
believe in climate change and climate
science and bastardi starts rattling off
right-wing talking points interspersed
with the word climate change he throws
the word vaccine and covet in there as
well I challenge you to figure out what
the hell this guy is talking about okay
let's get into it I don't know I've been
given this it's a lot of thought today
because I had to drive from uh oh guys
he's been thinking that can't be good
Iowa City all the way to Pittsburgh and
when I went by South Bend oddly enough
it hit me there are three possibilities
here in my opinion just looking at this
okay first is they've all got climate
vaccines we don't know about them but
unlike the covet vaccine they actually
work so whatever they do they're immune
from it so that's a possibility that's a
long time the second Tucker is that if
bad weather stops air travel
it stops car travel if you can cause
more bad weather right
then guess what even Tucker is having
trouble following this or pretending to
because that's really all he does at the
end of the day everybody can't drive for
instance next week and the week after
watch how much bad weather comes into
the United States it's going to be the
coldest snowiest period around the
Christmas time since 2000 so now I think
what he's doing right now is it's going
to snow in December so climate change
couldn't possibly be real I I think that
that's what this part of the diatribe is
we're going to see planes and trades and
all these other things shut down so if
you just dump all the CO2 in the
atmosphere and your assumption is hey
CO2 causes bad weather if I can cause
more bad weather then guess what if
you're watching Tucker isn't Frozen he
just looks really confused he's in like
a confused trance people won't be able
to fly will have less CO2 emissions or
or the third possibility exactly what
you said it's a phony climate War it's
fraudulent you could tell back when we
talked back in in July we were talking
about it's going to get cold early this
year across the United States that has
nothing to do with CO2 what it has to do
is the natural cycles of the weather and
what's happened is these people have
taken advantage of people who fall prey
to this and this is what they're doing
there's no logic or reason for it except
they are trying to establish a caste
system that destroys the greatest
experiment a caste system freedom and
individuality which is this country
right here in the United States of
course I mean if you really believe that
carbon was a pollutant you would be
planting Pine and Spruce and Hemlock and
Evergreens across the country but
they're cutting them down to make way
for highways dollar stores that's a
completely unrelated issue and chucker
now pretending to be a a tree-saving
environmentalist is really the cherry on
top that rant that's scrambled mess of
what I believe qualifies as English
language words that's what's going on in
the heads of many of these right Wingers
when you know when when our
correspondent Luke Beasley uh the bee's
knees or whoever they go to the Trump
rallies and they talk to these trumpists
and it's just stuff is coming out you
hear noise coming out of the mouth but
it doesn't really make any sense
this is what's going on in their brain
this is what's going on in their brain
it's just saying climate change every
few seconds while throwing in other
right-wing talking points and this is
that this guy is an outspoken climate
denier he's written books about it uh
the scientific consensus is completely
at odds with everything that he says he
said the world is warmer uh it was
warmer in the 30s than today as as
measured how and in what context and
what does that really matter at the end
of the day he says that human
contributions to carbon dioxide are so
small that they couldn't possibly have
any effect science does not agree with
that
um it's a complete and total mess and so
this is sort of like the blind leading
the blind it's the perfect audience the
Fox News audience but these folks are
dangerous because next thing you know
you'll go on the conservative subreddit
and people are repeating the this guy's
exact talking points so this stuff
spreads like a virus they don't seem to
be inoculated against the disinformation
and here we are left to pick up the
pieces and to try to figure out how we
can make some progress on dealing with
this issue sad sad stuff very very sad
stuff make sure if you have an Amazon
Prime account that you have subscribed
to Twitch Prime it's free if you have
Amazon Prime and when you subscribe to
Twitch Prime at twitch.tv davidpakman
you basically send us a few dollars that
would otherwise go to Jeff Bezos that
sounds pretty damn good given that it
costs you nothing check it out we're
going to take a quick break and be right
back
one of our sponsors today is Leisure of
NYC offering Ultra comfortable fair
trade men's clothing at a fair price
guys know how tough it can be to find
good boxers and t-shirts the Search is
Over All boxer briefs by Leisure of NYC
are made with amazingly soft moisture
wicking viscose from bamboo it feels
super lightweight like air it doesn't
Bunch up it's also great for the planet
Leisure of NYC also makes these
incredible supima cotton crew neck
t-shirts for men less than one percent
of men's Basics today are made with
supima cotton it's the best out there it
feels like Silk quite frankly you can
walk around in a scratchy t-shirt all
day or you can enjoy the cloud soft feel
of supima cotton and actually love the
shirt you're in these are my go-to
shirts and boxers nobody else even comes
close to the Comfort they provide all
products are fair trade with
sustainability in mind pick some up for
yourself or someone on your holiday
shopping list go to davidpackman.com
NYC and you'll get 15 off with code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below a series of text messages that
were provided by Mark Meadows Donald
Trump's former Chief of Staff are
absolutely chilling in the complete and
total disregard for the Constitution and
for our elections that they expose
particularly from some Republican
members of Congress including one guy
Ralph Norman
who said that he wanted Donald Trump to
declare martial law that's
m-a-r-s-h-a-l-l which we'll get to uh
this is really horrifying stuff
Republican Congressman wanted Trump to
invoke quote martial law to stay in
office based on some leaked texts Mark
Meadows texted with 34 different
lawmakers about overturning the 2020
election including a confused Ralph
Norman talking points memo has some of
the most stunning messages and at the
top of that list is this message we're
putting up on the screen from Ralph
Norman who wrote to Mark Meadows quote
Mark in seeing what's happening so
quickly and reading about the Dominion
lawsuits attempting to stop any
meaningful investigation we are at a
point of no return in saving our
Republic Our Last Hope is invoking
martial law misspelled please urge
president to do so clearly
Norman a fan of the rapper Eminem whose
real name is Marshall Mathers and that's
what he meant by martial law he thought
some of the songs might be useful these
are not the actions of a small
government constitutionalist
conservative are they hey even though we
lost and the Constitution says Biden now
gets to be president let's try to invoke
and use the military to keep us in power
this was an attempt at a coup which he
said let's try and do it and importantly
this text message was sent on January 17
2021 think about what that means it
means that after seeing everything that
happened on January 6th Ralph Norman
thought give me some more of that stuff
we need more of that the Insurrection
I'd like to order another one please
bring me another one on the Rocks so
what is our takeaway and we'll post the
links there's a lot of other text
messages that you can look at for
example there's like a Jason Miller text
message FYI I asked Ali Pardo from our
press shop to get in touch with Mo
Brooks since he seems to be the ring
litter leader on January 6th they say
they will have as many as 50 members on
board on January 6th but we won't have a
list of names until Sunday or Monday
anyway the point here is they were all
planning they were all involved it's
it's even more horrifying than we
believed and I encourage you to look at
and read through the text messages but
what's the takeaway the takeaway is this
is not the last time they're going to
try this they're going to be back there
was way more support for this than we
might have thought or hoped number one
number two the recent Marjorie Taylor
green clip that we looked at yesterday
where she said you know if I had been in
charge of the Insurrection I would have
been armed and we would have won means
that they see what happened on January
6th as a loss not because there were
crimes committed not because people got
arrested they see January 6th as a loss
because they didn't succeed in stealing
the election
and getting the guy who didn't win in
the Oval Office so they're clearly going
to try again they failed their execution
was horrible but it was clearly much
closer than it ever should have been to
being something that happened and could
have been their definition of success
there's no doubt what they wanted it's
not going to be the last time next time
the concern is will they have all of the
players in place
will they better know where it could be
hung up and be prepared to deal with
that will they have strong recover from
courts after more V Harper will they
have a legal framework to ignore
elections so this is a red alert moment
one of the things I always try to do on
this show is not to be hyperbolic uh and
and to catastrophize but this is really
worse than we've probably acknowledged
and we've acknowledged that it is pretty
damn bad so check out the text messages
we'll publish the links they're all
there and I'm sure by the way I haven't
looked through all of them it's
thousands of messages you may find
things that are as or even more
concerning than the martial law comment
from Ralph Norman let me know if you do
find those things I have never seen
anything like this maybe ever
a soaking wet Donald Trump
why can't they turn up the AC it's his
own house after all a soaking wet Donald
Trump who has barely left his home in
the month since he declared he was
running for president why isn't he
leaving his house we don't know was
interviewed by his own lawyer as if
she's a news anchor journalist on oan
and it still was a disastrous interview
Christina Bob is an anchor on oan one
America news and she is one of Donald
Trump's lawyers who tried to run
interference during the entire FBI
Mar-A-Lago search warrant She
interviewed Trump as if it's just a
journalist and it was still so
humiliating for Donald Trump why is he
always soaking wet we don't know is it
hyperhidrosis is it flop sweat we just
don't know listen to this first segment
elect committee they look at everything
other than two things
they don't want to know about Nancy
Pelosi turning down ten thousand
soldiers because he didn't
Nancy Pelosi did not turn down ten
thousand soldiers Trump insists he asked
for ten thousand soldiers there is not a
shred of evidence that Donald Trump made
that request for January 6th she didn't
look like the look now if you had ten
thousand soldiers for you know hundreds
of people they wouldn't have gotten
anywhere near the place it would now
consider how funny it is that when it
comes to the turnout in General on
January 6th Trump says there might have
been a million people at his speech at
which he encouraged them to go to the
Capitol but now he says well there were
only a few hundred people at the Capitol
now of course both are lies there were
not a million people at his speech and
there were way more than a few hundred
people there are 700 defendants who
allegedly committed crimes at the
Capitol there were of course thousands
tens of thousands of people but every
number Trump gives is a lie it would
have been there would have been no no
January 6th there wouldn't have been
been a January 6th so might be the
problem oh no well there are a lot of
people that think they wanted it but
she's trying to help him
but he won't take the the the life
preserver but if you had soldiers
circling and I recommended it strongly
that's a lie but it's her decision she's
the one that has to make the decision
that's also a lie and nobody likes
talking about that but we recommend it
because I knew that a lot of people were
coming down they were coming down
because they thought the election was
rigged we know and they were right
that's why they were coming down and uh
that's why they don't want to talk about
that and they don't want to talk about
the rigged election they all they want
to talk about is
the people and those people are being we
we just keep focusing on all of the
people that Trump motivated to commit
acts of violence and criminality but not
the fact that the election was rigged
because the election wasn't rigged we
did many of them are being treated
unbelievably unfairly compare that to
what happened in the riots where black
lives matter and antifa
killed people they killed people I have
found no evidence that black lives
matter and antifa killed people there's
an article that's a couple years old
from the guardian which says
anti-fascists linked to zero murders in
the U.S in 25 years uh that data has
changed there is now one homicide in the
U.S that has been tentatively linked to
a self-described anti-fascist
I I don't think it's convenient to Trump
to Compare the numbers to right-wing
violence in the United States let's go
to a little bit more of this interview
and it is really wacky
I think as obviously bad as this is by
the way a compilation from our friend
Aaron rupar it does if it had
starkly contrasted with your huge
success and
then there's that's a beautiful
journalistic question huh your
Administration was so good is that part
of why Biden looks terrible it's the
Keystone Pipeline Keystone XL yeah it
was all done they were starting and you
know the sad part is that's a union job
and the union head
endorse Biden
and like immediately after he gets into
office he terminates the Keystone
Pipeline right and that Union should get
rid of that guy and I'll guarantee you
the union workers voted for me I bet you
most of them voted for me but I bet you
they didn't the head of the Union
endorsed Biden and then Biden terminated
it immediately he didn't say he was
going to said he was going to look it
over right
but he didn't mean it was another lie
see that's the big lie not us they're
the big lie just it's just free word
association and Christina Bob is
desperate to help but she just can't and
they're the big lie on the election too
not us it's the exact opposite right and
then you have the unselect committee
they're looking at everything other than
two things yeah so then that's the
segment we already saw let's skip
forward a little bit to just a little
more Minneapolis they burn down look at
what happened in Seattle where they took
over a big part of the city yeah and
Portland just like people put up wooden
sofrans because they get knocked down as
fast as they put them up and people are
getting killed and nothing happens to
those people and yet with the other
it's it's like incredible not only
nothing happens you have people
Democrats
trying to get bail money to get them out
when most of them aren't in jail anyway
so it doesn't matter but compare that
treatment with the treatment that these
people are getting
and it's just a very very unfair
situation
it's it's just all over the place Trump
now cares about pre-trial detention when
it comes to the people that committed
acts of violence defending him right so
Aaron I know we're almost out of time
but I wanted to ask you one more as
riveting as this is sir we are almost
out of time Trump's like I'll say for
hours I'm not doing anything I don't
leave my house this is just one of the
many great pictures that you pulled for
your book about the rallies oh God what
do you think about the rallies I know
you have one coming up in South Carolina
South Carolina we have another one
coming up in Georgia very soon no the
rallies are incredible the rallies
honestly and you know it because you go
to some of them they're bigger now than
they were before the election that's of
course untrue and Donald Trump does
appear to be getting back into the
rallies what the point of the rallies
will be we don't know but at least in
theory he's a presidential candidate I
guess he'll talk about the fact that
he's running wacky stuff as delusional
as ever let's talk about one bit of not
so good news for for the failed former
president
a stunning new poll
shows Trump's support among Republicans
collapsing to Historic lows you have to
see this it doesn't bode well for prompt
and it does start to point to will this
guy even make it to the first Republican
primaries USA Today reports
via Yahoo news Trump in trouble
Republican support for his 2024 bid
Falls amid political and legal setbacks
this is a USA Today Suffolk University
poll and it finds that by a two to one
margin
Republican and republican-leaning voters
say they want Trump's policies but they
want someone other than Trump to be the
nominee
31 percent of Republicans want Trump to
run
61 of Republicans believe it should be a
different Republican nominee mostly to
continue Trump's policies which is funny
because it's like what policies he did
nothing other than putting in place some
confused tariffs uh they have a name in
mind rights uh USA Today two-thirds of
Republicans and those inclined to vote
Republican want
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis to run for
president by double digits 56 to 33 they
prefer DeSantis over Trump
these are stunning numbers I know people
will write to me and say David they're
only calling landlines no
uh Suffolk USA Today uses cell phones as
well well but David think about who
would even answer a phone call from a
pollster
okay yes a lot of people don't answer
their phone but I don't know that the
people who answer are disproportionately
likely to be DeSantis supporters I mean
it seems that this is a fair poll that
was done as correctly as any poll would
be done so this is a red flag for Donald
Trump and the question continues to be
can Trump make it to the primaries or is
support going to Crater to such degree
that he's going to bail to avoid a
further humiliation and cite health
reasons or some other thing that he
wants to do we don't know the answer
it's very early but the early numbers
aren't looking good we'll talk more
about uh campaign events which are
starting to be put on the calendar
sometime soon we're going to take a
quick break all the clips I played for
you today will be on our Instagram which
you can find at davidpackman show and of
course they will all be on our YouTube
channel
subscribe on YouTube okay
three I just got the November numbers
3.4 million people in November watched
our Clips but aren't subscribed if we
can get just a third of those 3.4
million people overnight we get to 2
million YouTube subscribers make it
happen my friends
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
it's great to have back on the program
today Joe Walsh former U.S
representative from Illinois former
presidential candidate host of the
podcast white flag with Joe Walsh always
great to have you on I appreciate it
David always good to be with you I'm a
huge fan thank you thank you um so okay
let's let's just jump right into the the
some of the meat here 2022 for
historical reasons should have been
great for Republicans Red Wave predicted
by some red wave that ended with
Democrats gaining a seat although now
they kind of lost it because of Kirsten
Cinema but it seems she'll still I guess
caucus with Democrats it's still sort of
shaking out
Ronald McDaniel was recently asked on
Fox News how much of what happened was
because of Donald Trump and she said she
doesn't really want to talk about that
to what degree do you think what
happened is because of Donald Trump
I I think pretty much the whole thing
was because of Donald Trump
um Americans rejected all these crazy
these bat you know what crazy election
denying candidates where did all these
election denying crazy anti-democracy
candidates come from Trump
Trump pushed them they came from his
stable they are him uh and and I give
David I give Biden a lot of credit
because he stuck to this defending
democracy thing uh when a lot of smart
Democratic advisors said come on
President Biden move off of that focus
on inflation and gas but he stuck with
it I think of a lot a lot of Americans
generally said we do want to defend
democracy they're assuming that that's
true and again when you look at split
tickets like when you look at Georgia
for example and you see Brian Kemp
easily won and then Herschel Walker lost
I mean not by much but he did lose but
the gap between Walker and Kemp was
significant it does suggest that
Republican voters were Discerning in
terms of which Republicans they they
were willing to vote for once we look at
that
we have a new poll that finds almost
two-thirds of Republicans even if they
like Trump policy they don't want him to
be the nominee in 2024 there are
increasingly analyzes that say Trump
won't even make it to the first
primaries is what do you think
I I'd say I'd say two things David he's
the king of this party he right now
Remains The Cult leader my former party
is a cult so do not write him off
at all uh but what I will say is this
I'm in a weird spot right because I come
from the mega cult I still engage with
the mega cult every day and I will say
two things about
republican-based voters that I talk to
every day
they all want trumpism
they all want that uh and we all know
what that is and increasingly they're
concerned and worried that maybe Trump
is no longer the voice of that not
here's the important Point David that
you know not because they think there's
anything wrong with Trump they just
don't think he can win
uh so will this be permanent I don't
know and and I don't the other thing I'd
say David is who's going to slay the
king who's going to slay him well I mean
it's it is interesting that DeSantis
without having even announced in some
polls is easily beating a former
president of the United States that it's
a signal that maybe DeSantis can do it
but you know when I think about imagine
DeSantis says I'm running and a national
campaign starts I you know I don't know
I mean Ken DeSantis actually handle that
I'm not sure I know DeSantis uh I know
him pretty well uh in in the pre-trump
days
um look he's got Zero Charisma he's not
good on his feet yeah uh he's very
thin-skinned and most Republicans around
the country really don't know who he is
he is a marker right now he's a default
spot for all these Trump voters who want
trumpism and they don't know where else
to go I tend to believe that once he's
under a national Spotlight I don't think
he'll do well yeah and and I've read a
number of pieces that say brilliant guy
uh much more competent than Trump but
sort of like constitutionally he may not
really have what it takes to actually
face the the national campaign with the
nicknames and the Deb but but at the
same time it is a different Trump I mean
if you just look Trump's something I
don't know what's going on with Trump
but when you look at video from six
years ago from from 2015 2016 his
facility with language and the insults
and the quips and whatever he does seem
diminished at this point to some degree
would you agree
uh I don't know but I do what I do know
David is uh where's he been I I get that
he had to announce a month ago because
if he didn't announce he'd look like you
know a loser so he had to come out yeah
thinking that the midterms would be a
big victory for him
but I got to tell you something David
every single day I hear Republican
voters tell me every day Hey Joe shut up
Twitter did steal the 2020 election I
told you it was rigged now this is a
huge issue an animating issue for
Republican voters it's a it's a layup
for Trump
and I don't know why Donald Trump has
not been more active I don't know why
he's not on Twitter I don't know why
he's not holding a rally somewhere right
now screaming that Twitter stole the
2020 election yeah it's it's strange a
report I don't remember if it was Vanity
Fair or which one that Trump has barely
left his house since making the
announcement he did an interview with
oan yesterday where he's mentioning I
guess some rallies that maybe are
planned but it's it's I don't know how
much momentum is going to be behind
those at this point is there still a
standard Bearer right now in the
Republican party that is the more kind
of prototypical conservative
constitutionalist small government
Republican like is it is it like Mitt
Romney maybe is there anyone left right
now no huh David there's no standard
Bearer for that wing of the party
because I don't believe that wing of the
party is a real Wing anymore the
standard part of the standard her Bear
for the party is still Trump until
somebody knocks them down and here's
here's
here's about all the time David I left
the party two and a half years ago one
of Trump's most outspoken critics I'm
still a crazy tea party conservative if
I ran in a Republican primary next year
I wouldn't have a shot because I oppose
Trump Liz Cheney could never win in this
party Adam kinzinger could never win so
if not Trump the party is either you
love Donald Trump or you'll be just like
him better than Trump I don't see room
for any other Republican for a while it
does seem though that in the right
District you would absolutely have a
shot doesn't it I mean if in a less
trumpy District I don't know a
Republican primary in a Republican
primary well I mean listen I guess it
depends to what degree the Trump Maga
Association continues to be to diminish
in in importance I guess I guess we
don't know
I I would David Peck I would probably
have better luck running as a very
conservative Democrat maybe so maybe so
maybe so what do you expect now in the
in these next two years because
of course Democrats will have the
majority in the Senate depending on what
happens with Kirsten Cinema it'll be 50
50 or it'll be 51.49 but either way it
is it's a majority to get things done
that require a simple majority probably
can't get much done that requires 60
votes over in the House Republicans
taking control clearly an interest in
investigating Hunter Biden maybe even
Hillary's emails maybe Whitewater we
don't know how far back they're going to
go what what exactly is going to happen
legislatively if anything at all nothing
right now that that for certain David we
know that nothing legislatively is going
to happen uh my former colleagues in the
house have made it clear and they're not
going to Veer off of this that they're
going to investigate every Democrat that
they can investigate and they may try to
impeach a few Democrats Kevin McCarthy I
still believe will be speaker but David
he's sold every inch of his body and I
know a lot of people say this I said
this a long time ago Marjorie Taylor
green will be the speaker in reality
really you'll be squeezing McCarthy so
hard for two years it it's it's going to
be her and the other thing we know these
next two years are going to be like is
it's going to be Trump craziness I think
he's going to be indicted I think he may
be indicted a couple times and then what
do Republican party voters do do they
rally around him do they say that's it I
don't know
when it comes to the hunter Biden stuff
I haven't heard you weigh in on it you
know my view has been
I don't really care about Hunter Biden
in the sense that he has nothing to do
with the administration if he did commit
some crime and you can prove it
investigate indict what what I just
don't care I've no it's like I wasn't
out there defending Anthony Weiner and I
just I don't really care it's the
problem I have is it's being used to
attack Joe Biden in a way that seems
disconnected from the facts that we have
right now what is your sense of the of
the entire Hunter Biden situation it's
it's uh David you nailed it it's purely
political I mean I've had some
Republicans tell me privately
that they have to go after Hunter Biden
because the base is demanding it look
let's let's be real I think you and I
are consistent on this it pisses me off
to no end when people use their service
or their family servicing government to
enrich themselves Jared Kushner did that
Hunter Biden did that with his dad for
years that's not his dad that's him the
justice department will decide what they
want to do with him but this is just
David this is red meat red meat for the
base and they have to throw some of this
stuff at them for these two years do you
think they will go as far in the house
as to actually try to impeach Joe Biden
no uh I I I don't I there are some in
the caucus who want to but I think
generally as McCarthy is trying to
become speaker he's cutting deals with
everybody
I believe that's probably one promise he
couldn't make
um as you mentioned uh even though
you've left the Republican party and
you're anti-trump you were one of the
prominent voices in the Tea Party
Movement back in you know 2010-ish and
at the time quite quite a strong
opponent of pres then President Barack
Obama's in retrospect Obama wasn't
really too bad right even even by your
standards
David when I look back sometimes I want
to slap myself upside the head because
you're right Obama Obama wasn't a crazy
leftist
uh in being in Congress then and that
the talking points were always we had to
call them a socialist and all of the
rest yeah and I engaged in too much of
that but oh my God no no not at all and
I've I've obviously over the years
gained much respect for Barack Obama
even if I still genuinely disagree with
him on most policy issues to talk about
a policy issue because last time we did
this and it was interesting on taxes
right so top federal tax rate right now
is 37 and there's the idea of maybe it
would go a little higher if Joe Biden
got his way but we're talking about a
couple points and then some say well we
should have a higher bracket that starts
higher with an even higher tax rate what
do you think about the level of federal
taxation in the U.S right now like what
would if it was just up to you how would
you organize tax brackets If I Were King
of the world David yeah I I'd get rid of
our complicated tax code uh I my my my
innate default is always to let every
American keep more the money they make
I'd I'd Advocate and push some sort of
flat tax one single rate for everybody
I'd get low-income people off of it but
everybody else would pay the straight 25
26 percent of what you make and be done
with all these complications and all
these wealthy people who can hire all
these accountants and lawyers to end up
paying nothing well so that's the
critical question when people bring up a
flat tax which is okay
you deal with Folks at the lower end by
saying it's actually zero up until a
certain point but then the first
question becomes is there a single
dollar number at which it goes from 0 to
26 because then that's the first thing
people would gain right to try to stay
right below that because 0 to 26 is a
big difference
so so one one way around that is to just
incrementally raise it to a certain
point so it's no longer flat is it then
it's no longer flat but it tops off at a
rate but I I hear that concern and
that's a concern I've always had I'm not
I'm less concerned about that than uh
the multitude of rates that create the
multitude of complication that people
like you and I just can't take advantage
of so then the critical part really is
at the top because effective
these billionaires aren't paying 26
right now so right now if you do a flat
tax that phases in at the bottom from
zero that's so it's already kind of
progressive then
what do you do at the top to prevent
getting deductions and carry a lot you
know interest carry forwards and all
these things how do you really make a
billionaire pay 26 effective because for
most of them that's an increase in what
they pay well so so and again we're
talking Pie in the Sky dreams of course
of course just remember I'm I'm king of
the world yes if I put that number in
there that flat rate of 26 27 28 yep I
would get rid of every deduction every
exemption everything on the books I'd
remove all of it
in my dream world
what about wages versus capital gains
that's another way right which is well
sure it's 26 percent flat but I can pay
much less depending on what it is by not
taking a salary as many of these guys
don't what do you do about that
I've I've always
uh
great stuff David damn it and I miss
this stuff do this I'd get rid of the
capital gains tax don't just make it
earning same as income
yeah yeah don't don't throw anything at
me I'd probably I'd probably just just
count it as straight income and I'd get
rid of the capital I'd get rid of every
exception and I would count everything
as income what's crazy about this plan
is it's not very right wing really I
mean like as we talk through it you're
basically saying tax capital gains is
income which increases the amount rich
people pay take away the loopholes and
the deductions which if you can get the
very rich to pay an effective rate of 26
they're actually paying more and just
make it Progressive from zero up to that
26 at the bottom it's it's probably
something a lot of left Wingers would
get behind I mean it doesn't sound bad
to me would it in your mind David would
it end up bringing in more Revenue than
what we're bringing in now I don't know
but it sounds like it might it might
yeah it actually that's the weird funny
thing is it actually might yeah
policy folks we've been speaking but by
the way David neither political party is
incentivized right to go down that road
absolutely absolutely former Republican
Congressman Joe Walsh you can hear him
on white flag with Joe Walsh always
great having you on keep doing your
thing David thank you man
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show if you
thought we had finally heard the last of
failed Arizona gubernatorial Republican
candidate Carrie Lake you were wrong she
is continuing to make all sorts of
outlandish claims about the things she's
going to do to I guess try to steal an
election she lost to Katie Hobbs whose
election win has been certified and who
listen very carefully here will be the
governor of Arizona Katie Hobbs will be
the governor of Arizona care Lake will
not be the governor of Arizona because
Katie Hobbs got more votes and that's
the way the system works that's a good
thing if the person who got the fewest
votes became the governor that would be
a real problem Kerry Lake seems I guess
to have found an ally in Stephen Bannon
and here is Steve Bannon visibly
struggling to cope with Carrie Lake's
loss and he's struggling so badly he
starts making up words if she had the
receipts to show that she was legitimate
she would come forth and and answer all
this all they're doing is obsficating
obscating careful careful careful
obsficating the reason is they ain't got
the receipts that's right I understand
that this election was stolen let me
underline that five times stolen this
really misunderstands burden of proof
and this is a real classic from the
right they did this with 2020 as well
well
we've got all these suspicious things
that happened prove Joe Biden really won
that's the wrong burden of proof Katie
Hobbs got more votes and won no one has
brought forward a bona fide legitimate
challenge to that why does Katie Hobbs
now need to do anything the election is
over the votes were counted Kerry Lake
and Steve Bannon and Trump and their
cronies haven't been able to demonstrate
that the person who won didn't really
win Katie Hobbs doesn't have to present
anything to them and this is a regular
thing that they do uh flip the burden of
proof uh here's Carrie Lake now defiant
they're not going to keep stealing
elections well they haven't stolen any
any carry if they think they can
continue to steal and rig elections they
are messing with the wrong people
because if we they don't think that they
haven't done it they don't stand up
right now Steve and fight for this at
this moment I know people are tired but
this is the moment we need to get into
it's game over it's the country's let's
not let them rig any more elections I
mean they haven't rigged any so that's a
good track record and let's make sure
that they don't start these folks are
completely delusional here's just one
more clip just it's it's it's copium my
friends I mean Kerry Lake who is let me
be blunt
when you look at the analysis you look
at the data you look at this lawsuit is
the governor elect of Arizona she is not
the governor-elect of Arizona she lost
do you think Steve Bannon believes this
crap for a second I have a really hard
time believing that he does she there's
just no doubt she won this election okay
and they've circled the wagons to
protect Katie Hobbs and this is going to
be a battle royale because if there's
going to be no battle
the election's been certified for Katie
hubs Katie Hobbs will be the governor
there will there's no battle other than
in their minds you're if you're in for a
penny you've got to be in for a pound
here on this fight right and the fight
is in Arizona and the fight is in
Arizona today yeah there's no fight I
mean yes they are submitting what they
claim to be legal complaints and maybe
some qualify as legal complaints there
is no fight in so far as Katie Hobbs
will be sworn I mean I hate to even say
it unless she's dead Katie Hobbs will be
sworn in as the governor
and that's it
that's the end of it Arana McDaniel is
the chair of the Republican National
Committee and she is trying to beat off
a challenge from pillow Mike pillow is
challenging Ronna McDaniel uh for the
RNC chairship chairpersonship and
McDaniel appeared on Fox news with
Stuart Varney and Varney to his credit
asked a perfectly fine question which is
you know it didn't go that well for
republicans in the November 8th 2022
midterms does Trump bear some
responsibility for that and Rana
McDaniel did not like that question
would you publicly say that Donald Trump
Bears any responsibility for the sum of
the losses in the midterm elections
would you say that probably I don't like
this I don't like these parceling out
because he supported Ted Budd who won
and he supported JD Vance who won I
think there's a lot of things that's why
I've put together we're going to go back
to that that's an interesting statement
Your Action Report we've got to look at
Dobbs but here's the one thing that I
think people should be talking about the
amount of ticket splitting the amount of
Republicans that went out and voted for
Republican at the top of the ticket look
at Arizona the top vote getter is a
republican look at a Georgia we had
eight of nine Statewide races won by
Republicans but why are Republicans
going and voting for one Republican and
not the other because they put out
uniquely disastrous candidates
disastrous candidates people like Carey
Lake people like Herschel Walker Doug
mastriana one of the most disastrous
possible people that they that's why the
ticket splitting is happening they have
to work hard to bring those Independence
isn't it
yeah I'm saying I'm not into the blame
game right now I think we've got to do
she's like we've got to figure out why
that happened well here's one reason why
it might have happened oh yeah but I
don't want to be doing the blame game
you said you want the answer but you
don't want that answer I guess analysis
I think it's too quick and I think you
can't parcel out will this endorsement
help this one and this it's the whole
message it's what did each candidate do
what was their turnout but most
importantly how do we get independence
to support Republicans and yeah I mean
listen I say study it study it but when
you ask yourself well why did Brian Kemp
win so easily in Georgia and Herschel
Walker lost Herschel Walker was a
uniquely disastrous candidate and by the
way he almost won like it it fortunately
it didn't happen but he almost won uh
the other I mean listen I don't know to
what degree Ronald McDaniel is telling
us what she really believes or she has
to put on a face right but McCain voters
are not necessarily the types of people
who are going to get behind Kerry Lake
because Trump said vote lake so I I
don't know how you disassociate the Maga
candidate even if you don't want to
point to Trump specifically from some of
these decisions that took place and they
talk about Let's do an analysis do an
analysis they'll never accept the
analysis of what it points to is Trump
just really messed things up or at least
publicly they they won't
um we're going to continue having this
conversation because it is a very
interesting one but I question
to what degree they honestly want the
actual answer it seems increasingly the
Republican voters have figured out the
answer because we looked at that poll in
the last segment or previous segment
um which found that two-thirds of
Republicans don't want Trump to be the
nominee those are pretty significant
numbers we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 David P here's a funny
thing we heard about this at one point I
think it was actually people around
Trump who would say things like you know
Biden doesn't have the rally crowds and
he doesn't have the live stream viewers
and he doesn't have the Twitter
followers so how could he possibly have
won here's a guy who called in very
angry with me who has a Twitter based
analysis of Biden vs Trump listen
yes my question to you is how many
followers does Biden have on Twitter
don't know and how many followers does
Trump have I don't know
maybe you should do your research
and see who has more four times as many
followers within a month or two and why
would I care about that in the city that
has been in the white house for two
years okay you're the Biggest Loser on
TV right now maybe I am but that doesn't
have anything to do with who won in 2020
and I can argue every one of your points
that you have nothing to back up your
facts with I encourage you to call in
anytime sir you just say things like the
election was not rigged this that and
the other even though they're proof to
the other side there's no poof there's
no poof nor proof
that it was and that's not a fact so you
cannot bring that that opposite effect
this is the burden of proof thing
they have not demonstrated with any
evidence
that we should distrust the results the
default is because elections have been
happening successfully in the United
States for so long
that when you see that Biden won by
eight million votes unless I have a
reason to doubt that
why would I question it they have to
present the evidence and they have not
because that's your opinion so stop your
[ __ ] opinions because you're a loser
and you're you're killing our country
you're killing our democracy yeah
January 6th rioters aren't the ones
killing democracy Congressman Ralph
Norman texting we need martial law
misspelled by the way they're not
killing democracy me saying
I think Biden really won I'm killing
democracy I think you should just get
off the air right away okay well let's
do that right now it's the end of the
show so I will get off the air uh we've
got a great bonus show for you today
though we are going to talk about
the pushing of anti-Semitism to the
Forefront
in particular by people like Kanye Nick
Fuentes and yes Trump has a has a role
to play in that we're going to talk
about that NASA's Artemis one is back
from the Moon with hopes to get
astronauts back there soon we will talk
about it and will we ever go to Mars or
Nars we will talk about that as well and
yes Sam bankman freed the FTX founder
has been arrested in the Bahamas a
Bahamian arrest has taken place we will
talk about everything that is going on
make sure you're signed up for the bonus
show folks oh the bonus show where you
want to make money but everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is
bad Pac-Man's a loser that may be Alex
but the bonus show continues and no
defamation suits with a billion dollars
in money awarded against the bonus show
I'm very proud to say that you can sign
up for a membership at joinpakman.com
you can use the coupon code 24 starts
now to get a discount I'll see you on
the bonus show it's a great thing
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the most
comfortable men's boxers and t-shirts
you'll ever find are at leisure of NYC
they're Ultra Soft bamboo boxers feel as
light as air and their silky smooth
supima cotton crewneck t-shirts are
amazing I love them you'll get 15 off
with code Pacman at davidpackman.com NYC